step back should be handy what's your
[ __ ] problem just leave man we don't
want any trouble a loosely organized
gang of opportunistic Raiders that prey
on the struggling civilians of
Washington DC the hyenas of the
underbelly of society who have grouped
together to take full advantage of the
crippled infrastructure and the
breakdown of government
[Music]
[Music]
we're the other hostile factions were
born from betrayal revenge or losing
faith in the government's ability to get
things done the hyenas are simply
looking to cash in on the current state
of the city when the outbreak hit
Washington the city went into panic mode
there were riots top-level officials
were evacuated and the city law
enforcement and emergency departments
were amalgamated into a single entity
known as the joint task force resources
were stretched thin across the city as
the JTF attempted to control the
outbreak this meant that there were less
people around to try and stop the
unlawful activity committed by gangs and
other criminal groups with all of the
free rein to do what they please the
severity of the crimes quickly escalated
and gang territories increased in size
this lead to gang fighting to see who
could carve out more of the city for
themselves however there was another
group that was to take to the streets of
Washington DC the true sons had broken
off from the JTF and formed their own
group the JTF and the government weren't
getting results so in order to bring
structure back to the city it was up to
them anyone who stood in their way would
be dealt with JTF civilians and
especially anyone who is creating more
chaos during the crisis the gangs of
washington quickly found themselves
outgunned and rapidly losing territory
the true sons were disciplined and in
far superior weapons and equipment and
unlike the law enforcement from before
the outbreak they weren't here to arrest
them they were here to exterminate them
something needed to change if they were
going to survive the invasion of this
new group it was a gang leader who went
by the alias of coyote who brought six
of the larger gangs together and
proposed that they stop fighting amongst
themselves and unify together they all
faced a common enemy who was too strong
to take on alone but together they would
stand a chance
can't do I'm not trying to lay down the
law but if we don't find common ground
we will get wiped off the map then what
do you suggest we form a council you
have a problem you leave your peace at
the door and we deal with it together as
an organization what is this [ __ ]
that's called politics so you mean like
a treaty like a treaty how you run your
crew is your business I'm game
[ __ ] it I'm down and fine it's settled
the other leaders agreed and thus the
hyenas were formed the hyenas are made
up of a number of different clans each
clan is self-governing and relatively
independent from one another the hyena
command is then made up of a leader from
each clan the leader has absolute
authority over his or her clan the
hyenas created what they called the
freedom Council this was the highest
command within the hyenas and consists
of the toughest and smartest leaders the
council is led by books the assembly
supervisor making him the leader of the
hyenas overall the council declared a
number of purposes that they termed
freedoms the freedom to conduct business
without interference or consequence the
freedom to accumulate resources of value
for the gangs own consumption as well as
for bartering opportunities the freedom
to prevent enemies from acquiring
control of any hyena controlled turf
books knows how to manipulate people and
has used the skill to gain prominent
position in the hyenas prior to the
green poison outbreak he worked in the
labor sector where he gained extensive
knowledge and electronics his
intelligence and ruthlessness make him
extremely valued by the hyena council
Roach thinks he's untouchable he relies
on his entourage to fight his battles
and never walks the streets without them
before the green poison outbreak roach
was a minor celebrity known for hosting
a late-night pirate radio station he
spent a short time in prison after he
was prosecuted for broadcasting with our
licence he is well connected among DC's
criminal underworld and has been
involved in numerous homicides zodiac is
a serious drug dependency and struggles
to function without
he is known for his violent tendencies
often calls for withdrawal he's been
accused of forcefully testing new
strains of spice on civilians
zodiac is believed to be in charge of
the hyenas spice manufacturing coyote is
cunning manipulative and never backs
down from confrontation she has a short
fuse and is always armed this has helped
to gain a position of power and has
become a fear to get respected member of
the hyenas coyote is the alleged
mastermind behind a number of hyena leet
attacks throughout DC Diesel is a
domineering personality and uses
intimidation tactics to subdue his
enemies but despite this is a coward on
the inside and all the others fight his
battles when he feels threatened diesel
is vain about his appearance and doesn't
like to show emotional physical weakness
dimed is highly ambitious and is
believed to have an academic background
he has a reputation for taking advantage
of other people's misfortunes and will
do everything in his power to solidify
his position of authority dimed will
never admit defeat
and will repeat tasks over and over
again until it gets them right deine
takes on the leading role in the council
and thinks about the bigger picture a
lot more than the rest of them mayhem is
a poor sense of danger awareness and
struggles to comprehend potential
hazards she can become extremely violent
which feels unsettled and often makes
poor decisions they have negative
consequences mayhem is known for a love
of explosives and is suspected of
instigating a number of us and related
attacks throughout DC but this alliance
is all smooth sailing between the
various pulling the trigger and that's
exactly why college doesn't so shoot
it's so emotional
sometimes you gotta exercise restraint
assess the situation if we do this there
will be repercussions and we need to
prepare for which ways just gonna fall
out
[ __ ] crazy a fall that's kind of the
point
no you burn too many bridges there's no
room for [ __ ] like you they all
hate each other who would gladly stab
each other in the back when the
opportunity presents itself the only
reason why they're working together is
so that they won't get overrun by the
true sons the hyenas easily identified
by the black pants and white shirts
under black body armor and gas masks
they spray paint their logo onto their
gear and green the general combat skills
could be seen as unorganized and
unprofessional as they'll often not
bother using cover and will wildly fire
their weapons without aiming generally
their combat tactics are to overwhelm
their targets with numbers and allow
others to rush into close combat these
rushes can often be seen taking drugs
before manically charging into melee
combat the stroke called spice seems to
offer the user increased adrenaline and
a higher tolerance to pain spice seems
to be a way of life for hyenas they're
growing labs can be found all over
Washington not only as some of them
heavy users but they're also selling or
trading spice to the survivors of the
outbreak similar to their past they mark
the territory around the city this can
be identified by the green paint and
fumes
[Music]
the hyenas are at war with the true sons
this was the reason that they all banded
together and because of this joining of
assets they're now at a stalemate with
them the true sons had organization and
equipment but the hyenas have been
numbers plus they've been receiving
high-end weapons from an anonymous
source which been helping them even the
odds all over the city there's evidence
of this war and buildings on the streets
the dead can often be found in close
proximity to each other in-game the
hyenas start off as merely a hindrance
to the division they're everywhere but
with a bit of patience that quickly
swept aside the first council member
that they come across is at the
Jefferson Trade Center coyote has
occupied the area and seemed completely
unaware that this is an sh t site agent
Espinoza had infiltrated the site to
reactivate the Issac note but was
captured by coyote and a crew the
division rolled in and reactivated the
note but were unable to save Espinosa as
coyote pushed him to his death from a
balcony in front of the other agents
they then pursued coyote and took her
down the next time the division run into
the hyenas was just after Air Force One
was shot down over DC the division end
up pushing through the hyena occupied
building of the Bank headquarters while
clearing up the building they find out
that president Ellis is alive and that
the hyenas had them hostage the division
rescue Ellis and quickly find roaches
team
dealing to him quickly eventually the
division cited that enough was enough
the hyenas needed to be dealt with as
time went on they were only getting more
organized and better equipped the
division agents led an assault on the
high in a stronghold at the district
union arena one by one they took down
the councilmembers books diesel and then
dime
with the majority of the council members
now wiped out the remaining hyena
members dispersed into smaller groups
around DC for now the hyenas were no
longer a major threat although heavily
crippled were very likely to be seeing
more from the hyenas firstly there are
still two council members unaccounted
for mayhem was in the district union
stronghold
parind defenses but we never actually
came across her she likely escaped the
battle and fled the scene unless I
missed something
zodiac was never featured at all only
through the cards do we know of his
existence perhaps he owed heed through
his drug addiction or maybe he's still
out there running the spice production
facilities secondly there are still
three cards that were unable to find in
the collectibles this faction is fairly
straightforward there were people with
ill intentions before the outbreak and
after they got worse the only thing that
stands out little is the way that they
held President Ellis's hostage it
doesn't really seem their start maybe
they were hoping for a good ransom but
generally they'll just execute them
without hesitation like agent Espinosa
or were they actually working with the
black tusk we know that the black tusk
was supplying in the weapons that there
doesn't seem to be any evidence that the
hyenas we're aware it was thin it was
just coming from an anonymous source
it would seem strange that the black
tusk would allow them to know it was
them because the hyenas certainly
couldn't be trusted to keep the secret
of the black tusk existence before they
were ready originally I wasn't going to
cover this group they just didn't seem
to be anything different or interesting
about them but I think they're actually
quite nicely fit into the story filling
the role of the group of thugs taking
advantage of the breakdown of society I
think we'd be missing something if this
group wasn't around would this video
have completed the four main hostile
factions of DC before I go I wanted to
thank everyone what well mostly everyone
for the support I've been getting on the
channel lately it's really cool to see
how many people are interested in this
stuff considering how early it is in the
lifecycle of the game this is usually
something that most people don't take
notice of until later on
this is the sort of stuff that helps me
get more invested into the actual
gameplay so my fellow law nerds show
your appreciation for the lore of this
game by commenting below with the random
statement of purple monkey dish hang on
I've already done that one um what about
negative Ramos yeah that's good one
there goes the true MVP anyway see you
in the next one guys
Cheers